- Oh, my gosh.
- [Kelly] We're very excited.
- I'm excited.
- Jessi actually was in the
thing you just said yes.
She was one of the singers
being here just for "Friends."
Anyway, we're very excited.
- Yes!
- We're very excited.
So everyone was talking about this though.
We love "Friends"
but everyone was talking
about this moment.
It happened at the SAG Awards.
- Oh yeah.
- And I have a question.
- [Lisa] Okay.
- So let's show the picture.
- [Lisa] All right.
- [Kelly] I've been dying for
another "Romy and Michele."
Like, are y'all gonna do
it, will you do it for us?
- We would love to do it.
- [Kelly] Okay, it would be great.
- Oh yeah.
(audience cheers)
That would be great.
- Like everyone loves that movie.
- I like how I'm acting
like, "Oh, you would?"
Okay. Then, yes."
- [Kelly] Yes, yes.
- Then we will.
- I am a decision maker.
(Lisa laughing)
I love that y'all planned that obviously,
you were like, "Let's
show up and do something?"
Like 'cause y'all were-
- Yeah, well, we were asked
'cause they said the theme
was back together again.
So they asked Mira or I
to present and Mira said,
"Hey in the script it says ensemble.
And so we should be wearing ensembles."
And I went immediately to
what we wore in the movie.
I was like, ah, I don't
know if I can do that.
And really sounds like a lot of work.
And, then someone showed me a picture
of this pink sequin tuxedo.
I went, well, I can do that.
And Mira can wear a blue suit.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- And she did.
- [Kelly] She did.
You looked fantastic.
It was amazing.
- [Lisa] Oh thanks.
Yeah.
And it's awesome.
- Cause people attach them, some
of these characters that y'all get to play
and we love and then
free all to like do that.
It's really cool.
It was nostalgic for everyone.
So, well, is it true
that you originally didn't
even want to do acting
that you wanted to be a doctor?
I didn't know this.
- No, that is absolutely true.
- I never heard about that.
Me too.
I was, I was gonna be a doctor too.
- Really?
- And then I was like
I guess I'll see.
(all laughing)
Like that's amazing.
(both chattering)
- Hey, that doesn't sound bad.
- Wait. No, that's amazing.
Not many people are like,
"I'm gonna be a doctor."
That's amazing.
- Yeah. Well my father's a doctor.
My brother was in medical school.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay. So
you felt that pressure?
- No. Not at all.
I found it fascinating.
I mean I loved biology.
I took honors biology.
I was like, well this is it for me.
For sure.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's cool.
Yeah. Yeah, but and the I-
- How did that shift happened, that shift.
- Yeah. Well this is a
little weird, but so,
(group laughing)
I mean, whenever I would come home
from like spring break or something
from college and I lived in
LA and I'd be driving around
and I'd hear a commercial
on the radio for a sitcom
and they'd be, you know,
promoting their best joke.
And it just sounded like it
was being like punched so hard.
Like, well that's a different
thing and I was like, oh.
- That makes me cringe.
- And in my head I would think,
oh my God, don't punch it
like that Lisa just remember
throw it away, throw it away.
(crowd laughs)
- And I went
- When you're in that position
- And that was my first thought was like,
yeah, throw it away.
Wait, what? why would I
need to remember that?
And those kinds of things
kept coming up and happening.
Like David Letterman
and I'd see someone on I'm
like, oh, she seems so phony.
Lisa, when you're on
Letterman, don't be phony.
(audience laughing)
And then I went wait,
why would I ever be on David Letterman?
That doesn't even make sense.
- You're creating the
vision board in your head.
I love that.
I just love the shift.
So finally you leaned into
the voice in your head.
I was like, don't do that
when you're on Letterman.
- I did.
I needed like a practical, rational thing.
Like you know what?
You don't have kids.
You don't have any responsibilities.
You can go for this now.
- I love that.
I'm so glad you did.
Oh my God, So I.
- I am too,
Yeah. Yeah.
- It was a life changing.
So you probably let
your doctor family down
but that's okay.
(people laughing)
- They were thrilled.
- I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding.
No, but your show, Who
Do You Think You Are?
I was so excited to do it.
Not only me, but my mother was
very excited for me to do it.
And when I did it, I just
had no idea cuz my family,
I mean all of us,
especially in America world
wore muts, right?
And there's so many different
layers to our background.
- Yeah.
- And I just had no idea what direction
and it was the coolest thing ever.
- Yeah.
- To find out about Isaiah R. Rose.
My great-great great, great grandfather.
It was like the coolest thing ever.
- [Lisa] Yeah.
- What's the coolest
thing you've ever found
out on that show, like?
- The coolest thing?
- Yeah. Just something that sticks out.
- I have to say the thing
that sticks out since
I started doing that show
was how much I was learning
about history.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- That you don't learn in school.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That there are these personal stories
and experiences that do
not get taught at all.
And just like the nuances
of history that are really
important to understand the
context for people's lives.
And so it's great.
And I'm glad you brought it
up because we are, there's
gonna be more on NBC.
- Oh! On NBC?
- [Lisa] In July.
- Oh! That's amazing.
- I know. I'm so happy. Yeah.
- What can we expect?
Can you talk about anyone yet?
- Yeah. I can tell you
who's gonna be in it.
We'll do six episodes.
So we'll have Allison Janney, Zach Quinto.
Oh, I knew that I would do this.
(all laughing)
Oh, Billy Porter.
Yeah. Gonna be good.
Nick Offerman.
- [Kelly] I love him.
- Yes. Zach LaVine and Bradley Whitford.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- Yeah. Yeah.
They're great.
They've unbelievable stories.
- It's yeah.
It's just really cool to
dive into that and I never
would've and I think just so you know,
it's a cool experience for like,
I just grew up with my mom.
- Like I didn't even grow up
with my brother or sister.
Like I didn't grow up with
any family, like aunts, uncles
grandparents, nothing.
So like to go into that
show and like actually
find family is really
cool for a lot of people
that didn't have that like growing up.
You feel attached to
something it's beautiful.
- Yes. Yes.
You're connected.
You're connected to your roots.
And you're also connected to the history.
Of this place.
- And I've always felt like
a leaf, so not no roots.
So it was like nice.
- [Both] Yeah.
I've never felt like a leaf.
I don't know why I said that.
(audience applauding)
That was the look of her new
movie "Better Nate Than Ever"
"Better Nate Than Ever" Looks very fun.
Can you tell us about it?
- It's really fun.
"Better Nate Than Ever".
And that kid that's Ruby.
He's amazing.
Well, so that is, I was told, okay, please
you've gotta do this because
this is for Disney Plus it's
the first film where
the lead character is a
13 year old boy who's gay.
And I went, wow. Okay. That's cool.
That's worth supporting.
And then I read the script and
it's so fun and it's so good.
And what I loved is that
this kid, Nate is different.
He's bullied.
His brother doesn't know and
gets him, but his best friend.
And, you can tell he can't help it,
but he like, just likes himself.
He can't help it.
But he just does.
And every time he is just
himself, everything takes off.
And so I loved that.
- I love that concept.
Yeah.
- I loved that.
- Cause I do think that's a good lesson.
Like when you do believe
in yourself the most
then things will start to happen.
- Right. Or it's just, you're
allowed to like yourself.
You know, I think we all
spend a lot of time and,
especially when you're
like 12, 13, 14, and 50.
(audience laughing)
You know, trying to come up with reasons,
why? Oh, I did that wrong.
Oh, that's not good.
Well, you suck at that.
- Self-critical. Yeah.
- And it's so unnecessary.
It's just a waste of time.
It's really not necessary.
And, and it's really, it's just okay.
Like yourself and you'll see.
Things take off when you're you. You know?
(audience cheering)
- I agree.
Well, wait, Phoebe
always played the guitar.
So did you know how to play
guitar before the show?
- No.
- [Kelly] No?
- No, but I thought,
- Did they terrify you?
- They wanted me to learn.
No. Oh, they.
- I love you.
(both chattering)
But you know, they wanted me to,
they said, we'll give you guitar lessons.
I said fine, because my
family's really musical.
My brother's a phenomenal guitar player,
and all the way back.
They're all musicians. It turns out
- Musicians and doctors. Okay.
- Except for me.
So, you know, cuz I pick up
the guitar and take a lesson.
So like, well this hurts my fingers.
- Oh yeah. Yeah. You get calluses.
- A lot.
And boy, I don't know if I really feel it,
or want to, but I struggled.
I kept with it, you know?
And that first season or
second season, I don't know.
Chrisy Hein was on.
That's the first time
'smelly cat' was on the show.
Right?
- Yeah. And.
(audience applauding)
- And I was saying, yeah,
I'm trying to learn.
She's like trying to learn
what you only need to
know three chords.
- I love her.
How Rock 'N Roll is that? Okay.
- She said Rock 'N Roll is three chords.
that's all you ever need to know.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And I said really?
She says, yeah.
I'm like, okay.
I don't remember those three chords.
(group laughing)
I mean, I think I remember
what they're called,
but I don't remember.
I have to learn every
time I have to play it
or something or do it.
- Yeah.
- And then also I made up
the tunes to the Phoebe songs
because I couldn't really play.
And I said, look, I'm
just gonna have to come up
with the tunes because it's
just gonna be whatever this is.
- But that's kind of what made it funny.
That's what made it awesome.
I think it was like, you
weren't amazing at it.
That's what I thought was, yeah.
- That's what I decided. It should hue.
I think that, but it wasn't like
you are just like this virtuous.
That's what made it funny
- Right?
She thinks she's phenomenal.
Just sort of like, you know.
- Circles back around to this boy, Nate.
And that's what he thinks he's phenomenal.
- Yeah. But he really is.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- So are you to wait, speaking
of Phoebe's best moment.
So Courtney recently posted
and I have to show this.
Cause one, I'm just jealous
of this moment happening
in the world.
- [Lisa] Oh. Oh.
- And I wasn't a part
of it, but she recently
posted a tribute to
another classic song so.
And this is yeah. Let's show this
- Lisa Kudrow.
This is for you 1, 2, 3, 4.
(group singing)
(audience cheering)
- I just had to ask you about it,
'cause that's Courtney.
Ed Sheeran, Brandi Carlile.
And of course Elton
freaking John, and I need.
- She's got fancy friends.
- What in the world?
Did they just hanging out at her house.
And her favorite part of the video,
gotta say is she's playing piano.
Not Elton John.
- Oh yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
I Know. It's like, That's bold.
- No, it's amazing.
- Yeah. But she's a great pianist. I hear.
- She's good.
She always had a keyboard
in her dressing room.
- Yeah. And she never
says anything about it.
She just likes doing it, you know? Yeah.
- That's so funny
that your character's the
one that was the musical one.
And she was behind the scenes.
- The fact that I played
Phoebe Buffay just
period, was the amazing thing.
(audience applauding)
- She's amazing.
- I had like nothing to do with her when,
when I started that.
- I love that character so much.
- That was unbelievable.
- Yeah
- Unbelievable.
- I don't understand,
like, why were they all
just like, come hang out.
Like I can't understand.
- Because I think people think
that famous people are like this.
"Oh, do you ever hang
out with this person?"
Like I've never met them.
Like there's not a club.
Like you don't.
- Not Courtney.
No, not. You can't.
Courtney knows everybody.
- Geez. I was just like,
this video is so powerful.
- Ed Sheeran said my name.
- Yeah he did.
(Kelly laughing)
I mean, I was so excited.
- I know.
- Number one.
- He's so nice.
- And then there's Sir Elton John
- Just hanging out.
- Right.
- Literally just singing backup.
Like, she's playing this, like I got this.
- I guess we'll do this.
- I love that.
Did you like the song you like?
I love Tony Danza.
That was amazing.
- Well, that was, yeah.
I'm French. She said.
- But they gets it wrong.
They said it wrong.
So I had to respond.
I had to say that's amazing
but it's you're holding
me close young Tony Danza.
(Kelly laughing)
You know, So I had to correct
Sheeran and John on his tune.
- Oh my God. I love it.
Oh my God.